greetings from podcast village wednesday
august [ __ ] bit
are you ready to [ __ ] set this
room on fire
the church is brought to you by sheetz
underwear
now that everyone is working in their
underpants you might as well be doing it
in the best damn drawers
you've ever had you understand me what
makes sheath underwear different
simple sheet underwear has a special two
pouch compartment
that keeps your [ __ ] dick and your
nut sac
from sticking to your inner thigh it's
like good fellas your balls go one way
and your pipe goes the other way you
know what i'm saying
they're comfortable they keep everything
together and they eliminate a lot of
moisture see especially now there's
humidity
and you get that nut smell you don't
need that in your life i took away from
my undies the other day like at six
o'clock at night nobody needs that in
their life
but anyway that's a complete different
story grab your nut salute the flag
go to sheet underwear dot com and press
in code joey
to get 20 off your first order and
sheets underwear 100 money back
guarantee that sheet underwear dot com
press in joey j-o-e-y and support those
[ __ ] nuts trust me
they're gonna be [ __ ] dripping any
day now all right [ __ ] kick this
mule lee
oh [ __ ] it all starts [ __ ] today no
more [ __ ]
this is the year of the [ __ ] soldier
we're going in like [ __ ] marines you
understand me
welcome to church [ __ ]
oh yeah i got a little snapping fingers
today it's wednesday morning
i got my man gene kirkland here you're
asking yourself who the [ __ ] is gene
kirkland joey
do me one favor lee tell them where to
go all right you're gonna go to youtube
and
you're gonna type in jimmy page p-a-g-e
with aerosmith
backstage castle dawnington
d-o-n-n-i-n-g-t-o-n
1990. do that right now youtube jimmy
page with aerosmith
1990. just put that in real quick this
video is going to come up go ahead i'm
going to give you a couple minutes how
are you gene
awesome how are you feeling beautiful
brother it is a [ __ ] honor to have
the photographer
of the rock stars in my [ __ ] studio
do you understand me
and you showed up with a [ __ ]
envelope you show up with a beautiful
picture
of guns and roses walking on to the
rutherford
19 whatever when they shot paradise city
video which
i'm going to take back to jersey that's
going to be right behind my [ __ ]
thing from now on it was for you man the
weirdest connection that i have
to guns and roses in my life but anyway
what's happening in your world
everything all things good man and
you're busy now that the tour season is
over
well no tourist season right now but i'm
going through my catalog
going through all my catalog while
there's i think you were saying you're
trying to get your website together yeah
yeah i'm going through
i found pictures that i don't remember
even taking i've got little richard
pictures black and white
live little richard i don't even
remember taking him i don't know
i didn't even did it i don't know for a
clue where i was at
i'm finding stuff that i pred i just
literally just found and i don't know
trust me i'm moving
i've found some [ __ ] that's crazy
yesterday i found pills here
i don't know who left them i went behind
i went in the [ __ ] record case
gene they were like perkis i don't even
know who left them in a baggie
and i threw them out i didn't really
throw them out i brought them home and i
put them in the jacket to give to the
homeless shelter
i'm going to give it to all those guys
let's put that jacket on put his hand in
there
and find some [ __ ] he won't be
homeless for a while he won't be
homeless but at least he'll be homeless
for the night [ __ ] up
but one of them fell on the floor i
don't even know what it was last night
took it i was [ __ ] up last night
whatever fell on the floor last night uh
two nights ago
and i picked it up and i ate it with the
stars i think that's why you were [ __ ]
up because the stars
i was [ __ ] up that night i'm one of
those guys bye look at the pill
you're gonna go to pill finder take a
chance columbus did
there you go you find the pillar it's
got to be and i know who left them i
i remember the guy's name who left the
batch here of [ __ ]
vicodins and percocets and [ __ ]
all that leverage of whatever so put on
this video lee
i hope you guys have tuned into the
video it's like three minutes and thirty
seconds
we're not gonna watch the whole thing i
just wanna show you guys
who the [ __ ] is in the studio just so
you right to get
right to set the mood where you gonna
put it on okay actually are you gonna
finger bang me the duty it's [ __ ]
wednesday
we open up if you're watching this video
to steven tyler and joe perry
overboard just discussing stuff but
behind them
you see a young quirky kid with glasses
a beard
picking his ear with a camera and you
can see he's anxious he's trying to
[ __ ] figure something out here
he keeps moving back and forth but
here's joe perry
you know persona of a [ __ ] rock star
now you see the guy go behind joe perry
he's trying to get a shot of these guys
they're both shirtless
if it was coveted season they'd be in
jail there's no social distancing
there's no mass look at him he's got
[ __ ] shark teeth by this point
the man that's sitting in this chair
this [ __ ] legend is shooting them
these guys are talking and who walks in
the [ __ ] room
but satan's nephew jimmy page now my man
doesn't know what the [ __ ] to do
he's going crazy look at the anxiety
he's trying to get a shot from the back
he's picking up a different [ __ ]
camera he got to get a line of coke look
at him now he's got the [ __ ] super
lens
that's who's in this [ __ ] chair right
now ladies and gentlemen
so if you're watching this [ __ ] video
now jimmy page
is telling harold smith they're going
over something like
what's the set list maybe you should put
this here and this poor young
photographer is going back to get a
different lens now
because he just put a lens in his pocket
he took the eight ball just in case
somebody decides to steal it he's
walking over
he's trying to set a shot up he's
putting his [ __ ] thing
this is the man that's sitting in this
chair right now so if you watch this
video right now
he said right walks right to you and
finally
finally as as as steven tyler
unpicks his [ __ ] ear they come
together
and they take a [ __ ] shot he's
shooting he's shooting you're watching
this he's shooting
this is 19 [ __ ] 90. this is
30 [ __ ] years ago this is who this
man is you can turn this off what's
happening gene kirkland
wow these [ __ ] don't know this
is how you come up this is how you show
up to a party
yeah how old were you then 27
20 and this was your life at this time
yep yep that was a
that was a daily that was a another day
at the office
and you would play these how many
[ __ ] times a year would you be hired
to do these things
oh all the time i mean i i that was a
saturday show i was home by
monday and working with another band
probably doing something with ozzy or
or whoever and then off again i was only
there for the weekend
they fly me in come in and say
you know do this for uh hang out with us
for a weekend
you know blah blah blah and then come
back home now when we spoke the other
day you spoke about uh
your high school days how you learn how
to take pictures with an oatmeal box
and lens and your teacher uh
you know you worked for him part time in
a shop or something like that
yeah take it from there what happened
after that you
you were going to go to photography
school yeah it would be your passion
i was going to go to uh me and my buddy
we're going to go to um
arizona uh tucson uh
i think it's the i get it mixed up it's
the u of a
a of you whatever it is the university
and um that's in tucson
we stayed there two weeks decided to
you know hey this is going to be great
and
on the way back home uh i was almost
killed in a car wreck
uh 7 30 in the morning july
31st 1980 just two and a half three
weeks out of high school
and it was almost over my uh
my buddy fell asleep at the wheel and we
went over a cliff
and it was in the middle of nowhere i
think kingman kingman arizona
and uh a truck driver happened to be on
the road
going on the other highway and saw it
and was able to radio the
the dispatch to get the proper
authorities the
uh all the medical attention everything
in the middle of desert
and um it was it was
it was life-changing because we were due
to come back
after the summer and go back to school
there but i
my plans changed so um
that's where i am now because i couldn't
go back
it was impossible for me to leave i had
my neck broken my back broken my legs
my right arm my shoulder my wrists my
hands
just a whole mess and um they took me to
a veterinarian
to stitch up my head because i was just
bleeding
i mean so much i had hair down to my
waist and it was just matted
and i think 180 stitches had to be given
to me and
then they landed a plane right next to
the veterinarian and then flew me back
to phoenix
and um how long were you in phoenix for
recovery
that seemed like forever but it was
probably about three or four months
oh my god and then from there you told
me you flew up closer to your parents
they found the rehab facility
yeah um they found out that one of the
best rehab
facilities around the country is about
five minutes from where
i was living my parents house because i
was only 18.
so um they let me come home and do rehab
they'd have me go to rehab a couple
times a week and then have
a lady come over and pretty much try to
put me back together again
and teach me how to walk and so do
everything
were you paralyzed or like what no i
should have been
i actually no i was paralyzed for maybe
about a
week or a couple of days i don't
remember but they
i remember um the doctors kept running a
um
it looked it looked like a pizza cutter
you know those pizza cutters and
everything else they run them down your
feet
and i never felt it and then one day i
could feel it
i said this this kind of tingles so i
was able to get my
my feelings back but uh yeah i was
paralyzed for a little bit
when you were at the recovery house and
you were in the rehab what were you
thinking about your life what did you
see
at that point our future
what am i going to do now i already had
it planned out so it's like now what
how long am i going to have to have this
the halo brace
i mean you know they had those um giant
cages i still have the little marks on
my head
where um they had to torque down and
screw it back into my skull but uh
yeah i was my friends had a good time
with me with that they called me iron
man
uh cage man cage boy they decorated they
got me drunk and
made sure that i had all kinds of
decorations on this
thing pretty much looked like a zombie
robot
when did photography come back into your
life at that point
well after um after i recovered
which was pretty fast um i
got on the phone no cell phones no faxes
for me no nothing i just
went through the yellow pages of uh the
directory
of um music people like all the record
company people and stuff and
and um i didn't have anything to show
them but just bootleg pictures i used to
take bootleg pictures
in the concerts so i would like
sneak my camera in and uh
i would buy scalper tickets up front
like the first five rows
i'd have to pay a whopping twenty forty
dollars for those good seats
forty dollars for fifth row rush tickets
or whatever i got
and um and so i would take the pictures
myself
develop them and put together
a little portfolio which was just
disgraceful but that's how it starts you
start little by little and
and um one guy gave me a shot at a
record label
and uh he gave me um he gave me a photo
pass because i was working for uh
my photography teacher he
had moved from high school where i was
doing my photography then and then after
my accident
i found out that he had moved to college
a community college
and so i got in touch with him he gave
me a a part-time job
so i could set up all the photography
equipment and all that stuff for
the students to do the developing and
all that stuff the trays
i had to put the trays out get mix all
the the
chemicals oh yeah my hands smelled of
stuff called fixer and dectall and
everything else so
anyway um they had a they had a little
college paper
and so i used that as my uh in and
i got a photo pass to shoot the band
outlaws now the outlaws were opening up
for black sabbath
on um no mob rules tools
yeah and um i shot that
and uh i for some reason just
loved the show i loved ronnie's
performance so much
i mean i've always been a big deal fan
since uh elf and rainbow and everything
else so
um i hung out with three other guys
backstage and
and uh he came out spent i mean
it was starting to drizzle a little bit
and then start raining and then
but he was out there and just talking to
us giving each of us
really good time signed my backstage
pass and um
from then on um a guy hooked me up with
his phone number which i thought he was
bullshitting
i thought this is not his number he said
after the tour
well after that yeah after the tour was
over and um
and i said i i wanna i wanna get in
touch with him again how can i do that
and this guy who had worked on that
sabbath tour was a friend of mine
and uh he gave me this number and he
said this is ronnie's home number and i
said no
nobody just gives you a whole number of
a guy so i had that number in my pocket
my wallet for six months and on
thanksgiving 19 1981 i think
thanksgiving i i just downed a beer
and at two in the afternoon i called the
number and
the man answered the phone ronnie james
dio i said
really this is ronnie and i could
recognize
his voice again and he said yeah so i
just blurted out
a whole mess of i don't know what i said
to him but he said
listen man um actually he said listen
kid
he always called me kid listen kid we're
gonna
have our meal pretty soon but why don't
you call the office
next week the following week and talk to
wendy his
manager and wife and let's see what we
can do let's see if we can get you
hooked up something and i did i didn't
call monday i called tuesday i didn't
want to be too anxious
so i kind of held back a little bit and
i called and um she was busy
and she called me back and so we ended
up
getting a meeting and you know she had
me in her office and
so i shot one of her bands that she was
working with called rough cut
and ronnie was supporting and helping
rough cut
because he would jump on stage and sing
a couple of songs with them
so it was kind of like i was she was
like you know work with my other band
and we'll get you in with ronnie and all
that stuff and next thing i know
i'm in the studio shooting some holy
diver photos
holy diver his he was he had just
vivian campbell tremendous oh he had
left sabbath
and um started his own thing i was
living in
a snow mass village and i bought that
cassette
and i i think i remember how clean that
album was and how tremendous he was
crisp and hard it wasn't i wasn't into
mob rules but heaven and hell
was a brilliant [ __ ] how and he was
brilliant for that how did he impact
your life
like because i know he made a big impact
i mean he
took you to the next level basically he
opened every
he he was the key to open to every door
i had i mean
um he gave me my first shot i
if it wouldn't have been him i don't
know who it would have been or how long
it would have taken but
um he
besides being an awesome awesome great
great singer he's equally a great guy
i mean he would he would just constantly
ask me did
did i give you the good pictures you
needed do you have everything you needed
and i remember going to his house to
take some portraits of him
and um everybody calls me different
names jean jean the photo machine
jean jean the dancing machine jean the
whacking machine
whatever it is but um
he called me jean gene the lens cap
machine because i was so
nervous that when i went to take his
portraits he was
he was just rock like
this is his first time the first time i
ever did he just showed up
yeah i went to his house beautiful story
yep and i'm in his backyard he's
all in a nice black shirt jeans just
just like something from the 70s just
awesome
framed everything right and um put my
camera up to my face and i
something's wrong something something's
not i'm starting to
in seconds i started to sweat like
what's wrong what's wrong he goes you
got to take the lens cap off before you
can take a photograph dude
so i felt pretty much like a dick
so i took the lens cap off and put it in
my pocket and
uh from then on it's like hey lens cap
how you doing today i mean
at the show is this like you ready to go
and
um
it's just amazing one of before he
passed away one of his last
messages to me was lynn's cap's rule
now what happened with the hearing aids
you were telling me oh oh
well hearing aid was done um if people
remember there was a thing called we are
the world
where all these are you for yeah all
these little pop stars got together and
they did a charity thing well
um wendy and ronnie decided to do
a heavy metal version of their thing
and say well we can do it too and it was
called hearing aid
and they pulled together people like ted
nugent
rob halford all the d.o members
people from night ranger um some iron
the two iron main guitarists
um uh
george lynch from dawkin um just
uh some guys from blue easter cult just
everybody got together and
and did their version and uh so that was
hearing aid and that was a nice
couple of days working in the studio
around the clock
all night there was about four
photographers and we all just
kind of went in different rooms and
different places and
just took pictures of everything that
went on
so yeah that you were mentioning to me
you also worked for rolling stone when
did they come into the picture
oh you did like freelance work for them
yeah rolling stone magazine yeah yeah i
mean um
once i started getting published in
different places and everything else
um uh people would find out that i have
a picture of
of this or this person or this and i
remember um
uh when i was working with sam kennison
sam kennison had just
did this video wild thing i think that
was a
wild thing with with all these major bon
jovi
[ __ ] aerosmith and and rat
and i mean just all kinds of band
members were in that video
but there's a picture i have where sam
and jessica han
because that was a major big thing and
they were
they were face to face just about to
kiss
and i grabbed a picture of it and they
thought that was great
and so rolling stone used that and once
they used that
i got calls for for other things too and
um
one of them one of them was a great
assignment i had was
shooting johnny cash at the viper room
i got a call saying okay we're not sure
if this is happening or not
but we'll let you know and this is like
four in the afternoon
so nobody knew what was really gonna
happen but um
johnny depp um he still owned
the viper room and uh
um i got the call saying johnny cash
you got to shoot this and it was just
him
one spotlight and his acoustic guitar
and it was packed i mean
it was packed full of people and
i remember somebody bumping me from
behind you know how people get real
crazy and they want to
get close well i kept elbowing this guy
in the gut saying back off man turned
around it was tom petty
tom petty was just trying to everybody
was trying to get in tight just to you
know get real close and
i didn't know who it was i just bam
crazy was the strip back then
oh man it was a different world yeah oh
completely different i mean it's it was
my greatest times were all the 80s and
into some of the 90s i mean when did it
go downhill you think because i got here
in 97
the coconut teaser was still open and
there was an open mic there for comedy
coconut teaser with the stuff on the
floor still or yeah the
shitty i mean you know i've been driving
past that place for the last
10 years and i always bang my head on
the wall
like what the [ __ ] used to be in here
that was an open mic lee
where was it coconut tease it was right
when you make the turn on sunset
from laurel canyon to sunset okay you
make that go right there
now you see a bunch of limos there
waiting for because now it's like a
fancy swansea
it's something private club but in the
old days on monday
we were on the walk to the comedy store
we knew the guy who ran that so i was
the first open mic
but then they told me that the guy who
owned that was responsible for like
like great bands or something lindbergh
i don't know what his [ __ ] name was
um whether all the coconut teas that
gave somebody a big break
well all the people that owned different
different venues or bars like uh whiskey
and the roxy and all those things they
always gave people uh
you know comics or bands you know
a good start i mean it's i can't
remember their names off the top i mean
it just seems
like there was no [ __ ] place at
glamour
coconut caesar was a dive it was it was
just like a regular open mic
it had sawdust on the floor on the floor
to help
i did it like maybe 10 times on a monday
night
just on the walk just to get light it's
just a center just a number
so i would go in there there'd be eight
people
nine of them comics you know yeah you
would just go up there and then
stop at the liquor store yeah because
that is right in the corner
yep got a bottle of something walk by
them but i told my month
and head to the comedy store yeah yeah
[ __ ] old days and stuff
yeah i mean i i didn't really
remember until i went to see a few
people there and it's like i didn't know
it was all
different variety but they had bands
playing and then
comics there and then sometimes they mix
them together sometimes it would be a
comic opening up for a band or
you know you know something like that so
you know
it was it was crazy the 80s were
very very very well they were
awesome to be i mean people really don't
understand the magnitude
of the 70s and 80s
they don't understand the freedom they
don't understand
they really don't and i notice it
because i'm so 80
and i will always be so 1980. well
because you had to work for everything
i've never changed my hairdo
i've never gotten a tattoo i've never
pierced myself
uh hey brother bro i'm never i don't
have anything from a society
you weren't allowed to do anything yep
like my society like if you had a tattoo
you went to prison or you went to the
service
that's it don't show up with a tattoo
because you climb the hill
they'll stab you the [ __ ] neck my
mom's older than you but she's
she still thinks tattoos are for
criminals and sailors yeah that's it
criminals and sailors you know it's so
weird how
the 80s was so
you know when the movie uh the molly
crew movie came
out oh netflix the dirt movie
yeah it opens up with a chicken house
and she squirts across the room oh yeah
you know
this was as opposite as me too
as can be the 80s but nobody's
complaining
nobody really complained from those
women if you really think about it
in fact ray don chung raised her hand up
about six months ago and said she [ __ ]
mick jagger when she was 16
but that he didn't impose herself on
that he's she's not even mad she was
going on there and looking for you know
they're 16 year olds they go down there
they go down there you know one of
felicia michael's friends used to tell
me
in fact her son is some famous rock star
that gave her an envelope and said you
don't know me you don't want to know me
i got another family this ain't gonna
happen
here's three three hundred thousand
dollars
to see tell him his father died in the
marines
wow and she told me some heavy [ __ ]
duty
stories of going you know sneaking out
throwing a dress out the window
with a mini skirt and walking down
laurel canyon who walks down laurel
canyon
everybody then everybody did that
sneaking out the window doing whatever
i never i look i walk down lower canyon
i see people i say a prayer from him
i'm like he's not he's going to be dead
on the walk up on the way up i'm not
even going to take laurel canyon because
i know there's going to be an ambulance
and i've seen it i saw a guy one night
at 12 from the comedy store going up a
hill on a 10 speed
i'm like this poor bastard and i should
just hit him and disable the activation
this is a nightmare he's going to have a
heart attack by the time he gets the
cold water
i can hear them and nobody'll know
another festival you did that people
don't remember that was a [ __ ]
banger the lineup was a banger it was
the u.s
festival no it was the other festival
here in
1983. i mean let's talk about music then
oh you shot that well actually the weird
thing is
i i was still getting started because um
the holy diver record had come out and
i was still on the phone calls making
you know making the calls
you know trying to get meetings with
people and everything else well
[Music]
you had to you had to really do it you
had to do
two things you had to be out out in the
clubs
you had to be out there being seen and
making the phone calls and doing
everything so i would go to
see bands see my friend's band if i
liked them and i knew they were playing
i would go check them out at clubs
or wherever and so this one guy
says to me hey man i wanna i wanna hire
you
to shoot some pictures at this big
us festival event it's huge it's gonna
be
huge i mean it's three days long
and um he wanted me to shoot it for a
poster that
him and um some other crackpot guy was
gonna make out these posters what he
wanted
was for me to get in a plane with him a
little cessna plane two-seater
and he wanted me to take pictures
he wanted something that was not
possible to do
but i didn't care i was just gonna do it
anyway and
try to figure out how to do it he wanted
the pictures
of the whole sea of people hundreds of
thousands of people
and he still wanted to see who was on
the stage now that's pretty impossible
to do unless you're
hovering over about 400 feet
above the crowd you can't get
that sea of people and still see the
band they're little ants
so i just did the best i could so we
flew
he hired me to um shoot this poster and
we flew out of van nuys airport
and um we were it was august
it was hot and um
he's flying there and we're talking and
everything else and i told him that yeah
i've i've
ridden in a few cessnas before and i
could fly i don't land i don't
take off um but i can i can
steer the wheel so it was fun i flew a
little bit there and
we started to get near the festival and
he was making long circles around so i
could lean out
through a window and and
take my lens and shoot shoot from
from the plane and so
um he kept getting closer and closer
to the ground level
and uh we were being reported by the uh
i think it's the uh fcc and um
we were told that if we do not leave the
premises
area the flying area um we will be
escorted down by some jets and um
so i think it was eight times we made a
a little loop around the whole festival
and i shot a whole bunch of stuff
and um on the way back
he started to tell me that he wasn't
gonna make it
i said what do you mean you're not gonna
make it he said i'm gonna pass out
and i said the pilot yeah yeah and
he was just about my age so
i um you're like a guy i'm like i'm like
10 years ago now i'm going to go down
like yeah randy rhodes yes no i'm like
okay what do you mean what's wrong he
says well
going around circles and that heat
because it's hot in the airplane
and um he says i got vertigo and i said
i said all right all right he says do
you think you can take the
and then all of a sudden the wheel
stopped and we were going so i grabbed
i grabbed the the wheel and and uh uh he
would go
in and out of consciousness so
uh i i didn't know what to do all i know
is
if this after this wake ups i'm slapping
him in the face
wake up wake up wake up and um and
you know you have to keep both hands on
the wheel especially on an airplane
um so i'm just kind of all over the
place and uh
um he finally gets on the the
radio and tells uh like a sort of a
mayday thing to
burbank we're gonna fly into burbank we
left out of van nuys
california but we had to land in burbank
that was the closest we were at
and the um
control tower for burbank talked to me
and i was calling him all kinds of names
saying you should be up here not me
i don't know what i'm doing up here and
um he just said just relax
you're you're flying fine just keep your
eye on these instruments and all this
stuff
and so he said you're gonna see a big
25 that was the the lane the
runway it was supposed to go on and it
was furthest away from all the
commercial jets
it which happens to be where all the
performers were coming in and out of the
s festival
they were flying out of that area they
had to stop everybody had to stop
so all i remember is seeing is this
giant 25
i'll never ever forget that this big 2-5
and
he's saying you're coming too fast
you're coming too slow back off do this
i'm saying you should be [ __ ] up here
not me
you why are why am i here what am i
doing up here
and i was just freaking out and the guy
um
started to wake up a little bit and then
he'd go back down it's like oh
man it was just freaking me out and so i
had my hands and trying to talk to this
guy and doing this
just about ready to land and all of a
sudden the
the steering column um
took a turn a little bit and we bounced
a little bit all over the place because
he was trying to
he was awake now a little bit and trying
to uh trying to
override what i was trying to do and so
we were like
bouncing a little bit spun around and so
much he got
vertical well [ __ ] [ __ ] i found
out later all right he had been up all
night
doing blow smoking the weed drinking
he hung over vertigo everything like
that so
i am found this out i punched him and
knocked him out in the plane
went and got a taxi and went back to get
my car in van nuys and
and pretty much threw all the photos
away
except for two i have and so i kept two
did you get paid i didn't even care if i
saw that guy again i was going to kill
him i was going to say
was that the last time he worked
together oh yeah i can't imagine him
yeah he's thinking about lee tomorrow
i'd rather be in that plane right now
we wouldn't see you again lee as soon as
you said spinning around yeah
like i'm thinking about leaving tomorrow
at the accounts office when they print
up the paperwork
they show them these sites you're going
to kill them here you're going to kill
them i'm telling you
we'll give you the back story later
people anyway
but after that but after that story
started to get around and and uh blah
blah blah people were like
all right you got balls you'll do this
and everything else so i started getting
more
photo work and all that kind of stuff
but uh yeah it's
kicking
yeah this is you this is all on you you
didn't pay for 28.
i paid 18. you know what best
not saying much more because yeah you
never know
god damn if we're sure don't tell joey
when you get a bad notice
that was a bad note that was a bad oh
this one's a bad one guys
only mush can get this one you
understand me
i'm sorry to interrupt you no no he's
not sorry
just look how happy he is it just came
back to me and when you said the guy was
spinning around
i thought about lee tomorrow spinning
around like a top oh it's gonna be
tonight he's not sleeping tonight
no he's not gonna go to sleep take him
you might as well i did take it out
we'll give you that spray thing that's
i'm high as [ __ ] right now
and a mystery pill and now you're not
even giggling at me
that couple sprays myself oh
god damn it you girls are so funny guys
no you really don't oh my god i would
love if we see gene here's the thing if
i was on that plane
and he was in the he was in like the
control pit
he'd be he'd be laughing the entire time
what do you want to tell your mom what
do you want what do you want on your
head still
i mean you would tell me all these
things dad yeah he wouldn't be
what song you want played at your
funeral yeah exactly
don't worry don't worry i'll be nice to
your mom don't worry
you kids are crazy oh tonight he's like
he calls up
from [ __ ] credit nobody because you
don't understand he's
they took his identity these people you
know
zip zip zip zip nobody needs to know
this they sold at lamerick park and i
told him this was gonna happen
he laughed at me he didn't believe me
can't wait till you're wrong and i can
just
just go la la la la la la la la la la la
la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la
you're gonna pay the more i go
the happier he gets look this is the
happiest he's gonna have this happen his
birthday
it's gonna cost you at least a geno for
an attorney fine you know what i'm
saying better than 48
48 and then the attorney wants 10
because he saved you 48
000 this is how the torture is jewish
person
talk about money and what he's got to
pay prices will come in with the neck
brace
and i'm saying that any day now he'll
come in with a neck brace they bang you
out with that bill you got a neck brace
you go over by that park and you slip
and fall and you sit there till i get
there i'll be a witness that i found you
passed out
we'll call the ambulance we'll do it all
high line we'll take you to see this to
the covered unit you'll get covered
that costs you 15 grand right that's i'm
just tacking on money for you i'm saying
the more the longer you stay at the
hospital you rack up the bills the more
you get in the settlement
and then we can scout the suit and get
to the bottom of this [ __ ] dick
thank god you're not my accountant this
is the awful advice what are those
gene what happened at the house of blues
talk to me oh
um aerosmith were playing the house of
blues
very first hollywood hollywood yes in
the comedy store
yeah right across the road over across
the street that's the stream yeah
and so what is it
it's a huge [ __ ] building
i mean you don't you don't see [ __ ] at
night when you're old
i miss life at night when i'm old
i don't know when i was doing coke gene
i could see through walls i could see
through women's clothing
i stopped snorting coke my vision went
to the beach i don't i don't see
dick i go to hollywood in the daytime
and i know this [ __ ]
i went last week and i got out of the
car in front of the comedy store
you got to see the size as [ __ ]
monstrosity
and they built it how quickly like that
that was torn down about a couple years
ago i think it was torn down for a while
and it was a hole
then they dug hole and they kept that
light for a while
because i would drive down that hill
every night i'm down there three times a
week
the sunset boulevard is not the same at
all not even
it is not even [ __ ]
close from one the i went down the other
day and i drove to lucianica
we drove past the shielding and we made
a u-turn attention
was packed eaten covered terrible
chinese food
why would you take a chance at your life
if [ __ ] chinchin and it's pretty bad
you might as well go to woohead and
[ __ ] said hey you got a [ __ ] spare
rib
i'm saying eat a cat while you're there
drink some
drink some [ __ ] bat blood do
something you know what i'm saying
i'm sorry no no it's good but no
sunset is you know even that story you
told before about the [ __ ] viper room
when i got here the viper room wasn't
really a big deal
i think johnny depp we did comedy there
on sundays
there was some guy that you went up in
front of two bands he gave you 25 bucks
and
a couple of drinks i went down a couple
sunday nights but there was no johnny
depp no more
yeah i think once the kid died rest in
peace
i think that that went down some once a
guy dies here like if somebody would
have died here one night on edibles
i'm out of this office the next day you
know what i'm saying i'll put a little
hat on him close the door some guy
doesn't know
do you think that some guy is going to
be it's going to be me
you don't get him started as soon as you
open your mouth he's going to go
i'm tired so gene how like can you put
into perspective
like how many people were there like you
back then like there must have been 8
000 bands but how many like
photographers were there how many people
were there trying to do
what you were doing oh we're done
i mean dozens and dozens i mean we were
all friends i mean everybody was we were
we were
you know trying to do the same gig but
you know there was just a little tight
unit of uh
of friends and everything else so i mean
it was it was like it was a handful
you're gonna be all right you're gonna
be gonna be i'm fine i don't know
i'm just sitting here highest [ __ ]
this one's praying
what was that gibberish you just said i
don't know who knows you eat brains
he's spraying all this stuff in the air
i'm gonna get a lung cancer from it
[Laughter]
trust me oh the problems
you're flying on one wing right now you
don't know
the person i'm telling you
his license is at the park right now
well he had a good question but the the
fact was
there was a lot of photographers doing
what i was doing and um
you know there was some old school old
older photographers that i looked up to
and all that stuff and you know uh
you're gonna land pretty soon are you
you coming down are you here trust me
i'm fine compared to where i've been
this is
okay this is nothing and but there was
there was some great photographers that
were in our little
group of people that we always saw at
the
concerts and everything else and i'm
still friends with them today and
we all agree that i mean the there is no
more scene there used to be a scene a
happening
thing you know everybody was going to
see this band and
you know you could always see your
friends at shows but you know there's
when digital came around wiped out
everything
it was not fun every i mean i remember
when fedex
came aboard and you had to have
something sent
overnight now that's not fast enough
anymore
you take something people want to see it
right away i mean
going to concerts and seeing you know
people with their lighters in the old
days was great when you know you had
your
big lighter and all that stuff now
people are just holding up cell phones
i cannot tell you how irritating that is
for
for me to try to get some pictures and
see nothing but cell phones and people
aren't watching the shows anymore but
anyway i did
i digressed to um yes there was a lot of
photographers that were trying to do
what i was doing and
and then getting back to uh joey's
question
um the viper room was
um i think part owned by
aerosmith and part owned by dan aykroyd
and some other kind of things that i
just kind of
listened and heard and stuff like that
so
they had the opening night of aerosmith
going to play the opening
the grand opening of uh the vip of the
room the house of blues so the house of
blues
wasn't even finished yet they were
painting
railing and they were putting in nails
aerosmith was doing a sound check
and they're still hammering nails and
putting up doors
and painting all the stuff and you could
smell paint during
the sound check and all the stuff so
anyway um
they do a great two hour set and
it's packed everybody is there that you
could think of
dustin hoffman danny glover um
oh that comedian the great guy chris
farley
um um steven stills
just a whole you know slew of um people
you know celebrities musicians and um
i had every kind of
pass and credential you can ever think
of you know when you go someplace and
they say
here's your wristband here's your
credential here's this
well i had every one you could have
every color every size
and i was following stephen tyler into
this private
little room at the house of blues and
my hand we were trying to get through
and i remember steven stills and
um dan aykroyd were talking and then
stephen tyler had my hand he was pulling
me through
because he wanted to get a shot with
somebody that was in there there were
some people that they really wanted some
photos of
and my other hand was being grabbed by
dan
aykroyd and two of the biggest
security guys i'd ever seen in my life
so
they were pulling me back out thinking
that i was a paparazzi guy
and hey this is this is you you can't be
here
and i said well i'm working with
aerosmith i'm working for them
right here what do you want to see
here's another pass here's another pass
so um um stephen's yelling at me
come in come in he's got my arm one way
and so i'm
right in the middle of a doorway and dan
aykroyd's
calling for more security because i'm
being pulled down by
two more of aerosmith guys and and dan
eckhart's people and
i'm just scr and and everybody has to
stop because
they can't go in because i'm in there in
the hallway
and so um long story short is i'm
screaming
dan aykroyd you suck i hate ghostbusters
i hate everything you did you suck you
suck you suck
and um finally he let go of his grip
and somebody was on the walkie-talkie
and steven just
yanked me all the way through and um
they sorted out i said let you guys sort
it out
and uh let me take my pictures now when
i spoke to you
you're a big-time aerosmith fan i mean
you knew
get your wings which a lot of people
don't know yeah you knew
the first style we talked we just we
talked about
kings and queens draw the line were you
a fan of this
before you took that picture or you
become a fan of it oh no
i've been a fan wait you're a fan right
all of a sudden you got a call to shoot
aerosmith
yeah yeah when was your first call to
shoot arrow smith
um i did a lot of work for geffen
records right that's right
a very very very dear dear friend brynn
breidenthal
was the head of publicity department at
geffen records
and aerosmith had just come out
with a permit vacation and she had hired
me before
to do um video stills on
um like robbie robertson yeah
and uh i had flown out to new mexico to
spend three days out there and
i i had done like lots of
variety bans for her um and she said um
hey you know what aerosmith's got a new
record out
and he she you know she gave me a copy
of the tape
and um says they're going to do a video
shoot next week
um i want to hire you to do that
can you go down there and it was dude
looks like a lady
so i got photos of dude looks like a
lady stills
and it was just i mean
i'm doing my job but i'm shaking because
this is these are
you know i saw aerosmith at the
crappiest of crap i mean they when i
mean
they were great on record but when they
were live in the 70s
they i've seen some pretty three times
they were only three for me
really oh and three
and then years later i got to find out
the history
whatever but they were very
i've always respected them in a weird
they had two lives man
they had two different [ __ ] lives as
a band
a lot of bands like ac dc had two lives
but they switched singers you know black
sabbath had two lives again there was
just
a switching of the guard aerosmith was
pretty much
dead in 1981. but people who don't know
this they were dead
it was just a [ __ ] joke it was really
a joke
and i still remember like i was a fan of
get your wings
i wasn't even a fan of the night at the
ruts not to mention what aerosmith fan i
am
dean delray reminded me of videos you
gotta re-listen to it again it's got
some
it's got really good [ __ ] really good
stuff
so what the [ __ ] are we talking about i
don't even know
about being a fan so now you walk into
this room
and what the [ __ ] how do you act i lose
my mind
but no i wouldn't because i still
remember the first time i had to shoot
something
one of my first big shoots had a shoot
with james coburn
wow james coburn to me is like my
connection to bruce lee
like that's it you know you know he's
not cool i just remember my mom going
watching him with in like flint and then
i picked up
the the second one and then once you see
the dirt on the
magnificent seven he drew the knives you
know james coburn was just
a [ __ ] and i got a call for three months
they keep pushing it back
to shoot and i get paid every time i
don't give a [ __ ]
then i get a call you're shooting monday
he's well and i go
whoa like james coburn i'm like oh my
god
and when i looked at the lines i had the
scenes with them yeah
so how did i i didn't know how to act i
was a young
comic a really green actor
how do you prep for that
i kept it together like when i straight
when i straight when i when i knew when
i found out muhammad ali was coming to
the comedy store i had like a thing on
my back
and i had this emotion and i broke got
in tears
and i did not want to see muhammad ali
like i
i couldn't i think i'd [ __ ] faint
you know what i'm saying like those
people i think i'll faint
like if i ever saw steve mcqueen in 1973
i would have fainted that's what he
meant to me charles bronson even though
he was a scumbag i would have fainted
you know
stephen tyler i'd faint when i was a kid
we're not talking about now i don't know
but when you're getting together yeah i
mean stop with the bracelets enough
you're 80 years old you're going to
breathe no please did you ever see him
on rogan
oh no bro that was one of the best
interviews
really he was when you watch steve and
tyler
you know that is a fake
when you watch steve and tyler you
realize
johnny depp is a mook little more like
he's just a [ __ ] mook when you watch
steven tyler
because half of his persona is stephen
tyler and the other half is keith
richards
he's just put it together but he's
really wants to be
stephen tyler but that interview that he
gives
is so [ __ ] brilliant he's busy and
all three of us put together
oh all the time he was talking about his
schedule like he read his schedule on
the podcast
because he writes everything down yeah
he's got to be here he's got to be in
there
it's just discipline it's it's craziness
that at that age
and then at the end of the week they fly
to orlando and play
something they do something like that
that's what he was talking about yeah
wow
so when was this podcast done about two
years ago two or three years ago
wow then he had joe perry on very good
very good
well i mean the video that we opened up
the podcast with what struck me most
about it was how
you know i mean you think of rock stars
you think of like doing drugs and they
just
hey it's time to go on okay they like
they were doing they were
figuring out who's gonna do what solos
where this and that it was very
bit it was almost like they were like a
sports team getting ready for a big game
they're like they were getting a plan
together that i just you didn't excite i
would never expect
90s they were sober but in the 70s
nothing
they came back they were sober yeah they
kept it together though they were sober
you could see
on their faces they were the sharpest
they ever were
when i saw them they look 20 years older
than that
crazy i saw them 10 years before
and they looked older from the heroine
jesus they were beat up from the [ __ ]
heroin
it was it's really a man when you read
the book
when they shot kings and queens whatever
you know
they were pretty much done they weren't
talking to each other just look up any
old
live aerosmith 70s stuff and you'll see
some
just horrid harvard not all of them not
all of them
there there was something they had on
and off nights but it's just uh
no i mean like tom hamilton always kept
it together and
brad woodford and all the i mean not all
of them were
in in certain bands there's always the
guys that keep it together
because if they were all messed up all
of them
just good night before you even open up
with one song
it's over when i think of you i think of
the guy from that
movie the young kid that the writer for
rolling stone
and what's the name of that movie that
that dude did mark marin's and he's
great and it
oh with the band yeah almost famous
you think of who of you like a young guy
on a tour bus yeah stealing a shirt
man taking taking stuff i used to take
stuff all the time
you know if i could take something off
a set list i'd i'd always grab the set
list uh
grab anything from the walls and you
know if somebody left something behind
it's like
they're not coming back for that i took
it so
yeah you still got this stuck oh yeah
yeah it's going to be worth a lot of
money someday
james you know what it's worth it to me
because
um like one of my favorite all-time
songs is seasons of wither from
aerosmith tremendous
it's a great song and they were doing
a video i think they were doing a video
in some place
let's see mississippi
i think or louisiana i can't i can't
really remember but
they were being filmed and it was my
birthday
and they played that song for me on my
birthday
seasons of wither and they hadn't played
that song for a long time
and when bands don't play songs that
they
used to playing they actually have to
re-listen to it they have to listen to
it again and again and
put the cassette or cd or whatever it is
and and have to re-listen to it and
remember how it goes
i've seen that it happened a few times
it's like can't imagine now you also
worked with van gaal
with sam david lee bros sammy wow
yeah how was that sammy's a great guy i
mean he's he's one of those just
straight-up guys that's just
you know he's a great guy but he's also
he was a great front guy for
i know everybody likes david lee roth
classic stuff
i like the records but live
to me dave just talks the song you know
how people
talk a song they don't really sing it
they just kind of
skip just babble through it all that
kind of stuff give me a favor type that
van halen live oakland 81 i don't want
the people to see it
okay i just want i need to see if he
remembers this
gene let me tell you something i in fact
my friends are going to give me [ __ ]
timmy halloween guy tabasco are going to
give me [ __ ] because
they tell me that
ah without i don't mention it
i don't talk about it all women and
children first
oh it's not one of my favorite albums
not because of the music
but because it came with a poster in it
of david lee
chained up in it and once i saw that
[ __ ] poster
i nearly [ __ ] smacked the [ __ ] out of
myself like i'm like i'm not listening
to van halen anymore you mean the one
where he's uh chained against the
fence right the third one late
so i was pissed at van halen
for years even though i saw them level
[ __ ] black sabbath
i was furious i read that that photo
almost broke up the band because that
photo shoot was in there
right almost when i saw that and my
friends will say you never talk about
that [ __ ]
uh song on the podcast uh women and
children first
listen to the album like well the album
is great i
went south because of that [ __ ]
poster i did not like that poster
but what the [ __ ] is going on i don't
know just keep saying error hold on
this performance here made me a van
halen fan
after the poster ah this was one of the
first videos on mtv
oh now how do you remember this and i
got to tell you
they are live in 81 in oakland
and they are [ __ ] phenomenal
okay this was when i was like wait a
second
i gotta rethink my [ __ ] van halen
hate
yeah you gotta go back you gotta go back
so
this is when from here on this is uh
the album with uh the second album uh
no this is the fourth or fifth this is
81 but this song is on the album
not women and children first but mean
streets this is well
this is me killing me i know it i i'm
from the offensive part of town
and they're singing oh my baby's on the
corner and she's looking so
fine 101 together and she blew my mind
manly loves men needs love to live
i'm the living proof right there this
van halen
i forgot this see this is nobody
remembers this this
is the first one of the first earliest
videos on mtv
and i was like you know what i gotta
think my advantage so i like this song
i looked it up and it's on the b
side of that out
that's the funny thing about that and
after that i became a van halen fan
but like i told you the other day i saw
a deal in philadelphia
and the open spectrum at the spectrum
and the opening band
was sammy hagar and shaken street
and in philly they're savages and i had
sixth row
and they were spitting on their fingers
and flicking it and sammy hagar
poor so that was my last real experience
of sammy hagar
so i'm watching this and also when
somebody comes to me and says sammy
hagar
is going to replace david lee roth i'm
like there's not a prayer in hell
they almost they almost spit out them to
death in philadelphia you know how's he
going to do it
but you what year was this when you
hooked up with them
it was the 5150 tour oh right
it's when they started right yeah right
there yeah
and uh i um i hooked up with their
manager
and uh the publicist and
once you get your little foot in there
and the door doesn't quite slam on you
and you kind of kick it open a little
bit more and a little bit more
you either have to do two things annoy
someone to death
or just leave i annoy people to death so
they gotta give me a chance so
uh anyway so speaking of annoying let me
talk to you about something like
really annoying one of those scenarios
i'm sitting here quiet minding my own
business
i didn't even say i didn't even i didn't
even fart yeah take another shot
[Laughter]
i feel like we're not going to see each
other for a couple months [ __ ]
getting it all in
god it was getting too quiet too good
team gene we gotta [ __ ] it up a little
bit
[Laughter]
ah i'm gonna get [ __ ] up tonight
that's a thousand milligram spray i
saved that for a special occasion
i hope my wife's got cold cuts tonight
i'm saying
that you tell her not to get cold oh my
god i [ __ ] get the worst monkeys in
the world i'm sorry
anyway so sammy thank god van halen what
are you laughing about
he just digging up with 20 g's tomorrow
no i don't look good
totally [ __ ] yeah tomorrow
and they look at you and they said and
they show you the bank accounts and
these you know that remote looks like a
bar of soap you know you better
oh forget it i can't i can't handle i
can't handle two people
you know what i'm on your side you're
gonna be fine yeah sure right keep
telling that he doesn't know
he started a corporation he thinks he's
johnny bananas
they're gonna go right in there they
already went in they ran like fruit
money
like call that fruit but people don't
know is all those umbrellas joe bananas
all those umbrellas those mexican places
they're all cartel money that's where
they drop and pick up the money nobody
suspects those little mexicans
you look at them they come like from a
third world nation
they're making two yards a day you think
you make any money selling coconuts in
this country they're in a dime in that
[ __ ] business
they sprinkle peanuts on it and some
[ __ ] sesame sauce
yeah you're gonna die they're little
transports for envelopes so
so what they do is his this
ex-sister-in-law
sold his id donald murk park
lee jump in quick i just lost in his
mind that it's a it's a
front for the cartel but they're also
filing taxes the city of los angeles
sure because they're nice people these
people
decent people they're catholics just
because they sell drugs what's that got
to do with it you know what i'm saying
so they you you're probably the owner of
all these umbrellas
you know someone who believes in karma
you're being kind of mean to me
i'm not being mean to you i'm just
telling you that there's no way you end
up with this type of bill
from the city they said i made 16
million dollars you did oh
i bet you did there's a lot of [ __ ]
fruits i bet you
that's a lot of
that just that comes out too easy for me
lee that's a lot of fruit
that's a lot of nanos sesame oil
how long did you work with them for on
the 5150 tour
um yeah off and on but uh there was one
really fun night
um i was in uh i usually just handled
some of the west coast you know shows
san diego
la um you know vegas
so i go to vegas and um um
i uh shoot the show and during the
middle of the show
um i'm in the photo pit and sammy hagar
leans down and he's trying to talk to me
and i i i don't wear earplugs
in shows so i can't hear i want to hear
the loud
buzzing i want to hear i don't want to
hear muffled stuff so i don't wear
earplugs so he leans down
and he's trying to ask me something i
have no idea
this is during a slight guitar solo and
something's going on and
he's trying to tell me something and i
just say i don't know
what what and next thing i know
he's grabbing me by
like okay i'm shooting photos he's
leaning down
and trying to grab the back of my belt
along with
two of his security people and he wanted
me to go on stage
apparently what was supposed to happen
was he was trying to tell me
there was a whole crapload of girls
with their tops off tit city
and he wanted pictures of it so it was
like
he was trying to get me to come up there
he's like
get up here what he was saying was hey i
need you up here now
and i'm like idiot and i'm like
so i got up there and yep
titty city that's my first 10 rows of
you know tops off and everything else
and i'm
just first of all i'm nervous because
i'm on the stage
i've never been on a stage before that
so i'm like
and um so i'm like okay
there's a nice set there's a nice set
and he's bringing me over and he goes
get that one get that one take that one
and
and then um in the meantime um
eddie van halen was running back and
forth and he would
like kick me in the ass uh with his foot
like playing and just kind of give me a
kick
and then um michael anthony
um saw me look one way and he threw me a
beer and
they were just having fun it's like you
know crack open a beer have it right
there
there's another set right there grab
that and then
i don't know what song it was but it was
just and then
a friend of mine that had gone with me
to the show i see his face
and he's just like freaking out like
you're up there look at all these i said
but look behind you look behind you
man so he was
he was more having fun with me being up
there than what was
behind him so do you have a like a file
folder full of these
titty city pictures well needless to say
the band took them
i mean i was working with them but uh
uh i'm pretty sure that uh the girl i
was seeing at the time
probably wouldn't dig that if i came and
say look look at all these nice
oh no you don't look at these so gene
when
are you retired now well um
no okay would you
have been on tour right now if it wasn't
for this pandemic
if somebody wanted yeah you would
believe they would gun for somebody
no or anybody i mean um i just did a
photo shoot
two weeks ago of a up-and-coming new
band that's great three-piece band
they're awesome and uh i found a
location
uh that uh they're called um
they're called uh okay they're gonna
kill me they're called uh
desert of desert of the talking shadows
and the singer plays guitar
and sings he's got a chris cornell sound
garden sound
and he plays like a little bit like
slash and some other people but
they are a great band and so they wanted
some new photos
and i found this um i went back to the
old school days
of uh the 80s where it's
uh it was a it was a mental hospital
that had been
shut down for 30 40 50 years
and it was all gated up and everything
else and
i scouted it out actually me and my wife
went around a bunch of times and
found different holes on the fence that
we could
crawl under and see and i took the
pictures and
sent it and said you guys want to take a
shot of
getting in this place yeah let's go for
it
so we did and uh so
you know i mean
photographers i was a horrible
photographer as as a kid i started
in the 70s with a kodak and [ __ ] like
that
and my hands wouldn't be steady but
this is there's something about somebody
shooting me and i look weird
like there's two people who could shoot
me that looked great
and that's troy conrad and felicia
michaels every picture felicia michaels
has taken to me
i could really dig him a couple years
ago a guy called me that i knew for
years because i want to run
something but i need a character face do
you mind
he sent them to me and i'm like man i
need plastic [ __ ] surgery like
there's some photographers that just i
look at the pictures and i go
something's not there but then you have
troy conrad and felicia mike
did you know them though yes did you
do are you friends and bond and you did
you okay that helps
because if someone that i don't know
wants me to do something
i gotta i gotta know something about him
i
gotta look them up i gotta talk to them
i gotta like
get to know them and get their vibe
usually the people yeah because
you know if i if i know you and uh
like i was like i was telling you uh
before
um my very first guns n roses photo
shoot
i knew that they were big drinkers and
everybody had cigarettes i spent 160
bucks on booze and
and cartons and cartons of cigarettes
everybody got here you want a carton you
want a carton you want a carton
here so i i did a little homework and
and uh everybody went home
hungover and happy or whatever
that's [ __ ] crazy man but if you know
somebody and you're comfortable with
them
then you'll do something i mean i've
shot some
photographs of some people and they were
horrible
we just didn't get on they didn't
want to be there a lot of people i bet
you went photos taken
in five minutes or less
too let me ask you this
now when you get sent out by the record
label you go to these different people
other times you've ever showed up and
you've gone to shoot them and you don't
really like the person
and you still gotta work that night has
that ever happened
you go to shoot a band you kind of like
them you know a little something about
them
maybe i don't like their music but i
like them
it really helps if you like their music
because you get into it
but yeah i've gone on have you gone to a
place where somebody's just like [ __ ]
like you this guy's a scumbag um
[Music]
yeah there's been a couple times that
that's happened
big stars like um they thought they were
they thought they were bigger than their
britches but
you know it's um
how long were you in the game for like
because
you even worked at roger waters i mean
you're with everybody no actually i
didn't work for roger waters
um i i see
a lot of times people get hired to do
jobs
then there's other times where the
photographer wants to go
shoot an artist or photograph a show
for their catalog you know i need i need
some new pictures of this band or
i i don't have any of this and the
publicist
will say okay you know here's your photo
pass and we'll
you know you're taken care of i went to
go see roger waters play
and photograph his show when he was on
his
first solo tour so
yeah yeah eighty i think it was 85. and
it was at the la forum
and um i think there was only
two of us or three of us maybe
in the photo pit in the front area
and you're given three songs to do
someone somewhere when i came along
i came along just when this three song
rule happened but
as a as a rule there's you get three
songs
shoot the artist and then get out well
i was at this raj water show and um
the song was one of the songs was so
long
and i don't remember which one it was
that the security didn't know
that i was supposed to leave and i
didn't know if this was a new song
or still part of the second or third
song so i stayed and stayed
and next thing i know i'm in there by
myself and i'm still shooting
and shooting during one of his songs he
looks
he looks down at me stops the show stops
everything
and yells at me to get my ass out of the
photo pit
what are you doing here who are you what
are you doing
get out i'm not going to play nothing
get out i'm like okay
i'm i'm fine i was just doing my
stuff you were hired to be there no no i
just
you know wanted to do it on my own so no
if i was hired i would [ __ ] hustle
yeah that's what that's what
photographers did
they called up said i would like to come
to this show and and uh you know
get some get some you know stuff
so obviously paparazzi has like a sort
of a negative connotation
but as like an independent photographer
is that how you would kind of do your
business like
you would take these pictures and try to
sell them to magazines exactly exactly
like like for instance um let's say uh
let's say i don't have any ted nugent
photos or
needed some new ones um he comes through
town
or rush or any band comes through town
and um
i call up and say you know to the
publicist or
whoever i have to talk to um hey can i
um
can i get into this show and they'll say
well you know we're
over our limit but um maybe you'd want
to go to a different city like
long beach if they did long beach arena
or
a lot of times i went to san diego
because nobody would drive down to san
diego and i would be
like the only one in the in the pit area
how many photographers usually go in
that pit area there's been times
i could probably estimate 15
when when there was an iron maiden show
in the early days the early 80s
i mean there was about 15 of us in there
scrambling for
uh for the shots i thought the bands get
pissed
what do you mean so there's a special
area for photographers
and you come in there and you just take
pictures of me
and you leave and you go home and then i
tour i never see you again and you have
my pictures
and sell them i don't get this well
the magazines need oh okay okay
no no that's what i'm saying yeah so
then you have the press pass
yeah that's what it is we went to see
roger waters
i had a press pass and and so someone
authorized it but the problem was nobody
kicked me out
and i didn't know exactly what point to
leave so i just stayed in there
and i'm i'm not gonna hey i have a
chance to keep staying i'm not gonna
leave until someone tells me to leave
and he i didn't know he was gonna stop
the show and kick me out
usually a security guard would just do
one of these things or
flashes flashlight in your face or
something like that get your attention
but never had an artist stop a show and
tell me leave and make sure i'm leaving
the building i'm not gonna
until you're out of my sight i'm not
gonna play so
that was a kind of a dick move but
whatever i had to spin this around
uh and take it back a little bit you
went on the road with aerosmith
but before you were on the road with
aerosmith
that's when you encountered guns and
roses
correct well i actually worked
with both those bands almost at the same
time
because um um i think
okay i think appetite came out in 87
and so did permanent vacation i'm i'm
pretty sure that those
and they're both on gaffin records and
they're both
coming out with uh pretty
pretty solid records well appetite
huge record and for aerosmith um
that permit vacation was their comeback
record
i mean it started opening the doors for
everything they did since then
again um so what had happened was
i was working with both those bands
in the same summer so i would i would go
from
shooting a video to a photo shoot
to some touring stuff and um
then the best thing happened was
uh guns and roses opened up for
aerosmith on the last
leg of the tour which was the last month
and a half for two months of
their tour so to see to see those two
play together
was awesome i mean now geffen's company
paid for your hotel
travel um actually they
they paid they paid for what they used
so let's say um let's say i went on my
own
then they would just buy whatever they
wanted from me
if they sent me if they sent me to new
york or sent me to
some place then
you know i would get what they wanted to
have and needed with their photos
but um but they'd pay for everything but
i still owned it
so if they sent me the her name is bryn
bridenthal she was the head of
publicity so she would hire me
and say we need you to go here and shoot
you know paradise city video
some stills from there but by that time
i knew the band anyway
so it was like fun to go get paid to go
see some friends play
and so and then also
aerosmith was on the bill too so i'd
kind of piggyback
so it was really weird because one week
i would go out
and shoot aerosmith and then the
next week i'd or two weeks later i'd go
back out
and shoot guns and roses but they were
all still in the same bill so i'd
still get more pictures he told me once
that slash was
very very influential on you like he was
one of the three people that were very
very good to you oh he still is oh he's
he's he's one of my dearest friends of
you know um and that you you mentioned
that movie almost famous
and uh there's a part where it says
don't make friends with the bands you
know don't
don't get close to them don't make
friends with a band they'll
chew you up and disregard you and all
that stuff well
that has happened but most the time you
know
um artists
they call me because they want something
and
for me too i call them when i want
something but
in rare cases people just call to check
in
um there are three major people in my
life that
that are huge slash
leader ford and um
ronnie james dio i mean
i'm so sad we we we lost him
years ago gosh ten years ago but
um he was the i mean he was my
my start i never i might not even
be here standing or sitting here talking
to you
because someone has to give you a start
you don't know when
or where or who but he was the one and i
couldn't have asked for a damn man
you had a second chance at life yeah you
haven't what are you gonna write your
book
i know you told me you're working on the
website
i mean gene this is a story that
we could do ten of these hours you know
from slash to you know harold smith i
mean
the other day when we were talking i
told you my love forever smith
and the albums i loved your head almost
blew up yeah i mean how old are you i'm
57
58. yes so we both grew up on the same
[ __ ] music
and then one day you had the the you had
a dream life you know
and you're still ticking you still look
good you're handsome
yeah you're still taking pictures what
kind of camera do you think your
pictures on
i've got a nikon oh no no i'm sorry i
used to have nikon i i was a nikon guy
forever but
i have a canon i use canon gear
i've got a it's a 7d
canon 7d and a couple lenses and
lenses are your favorite i'm a
photography guy
but people are photographers are
listening to the podcast
um it's a uh it's a uh
a zoom lens uh 70
um actually it's a 24 to 70
zoom lens 2.8 that's my that's my
favorite one
because it can cover just about whatever
i need
i have i have a couple of longer lenses
a 200 lens
if i have to be back like if i'm in the
crowd
if i'm in the crowd and i want to get
you know
a shot from inside the
the the arena or something like that and
want to get
a nice long shot i'll use my 200.
um but the one that that's strapped onto
the
the camera right now is uh the 24 to 70
and i can pick it up and it's it's good
to go it's ready to go at all times and
and uh yeah i used it the other day and
it was awesome
does it hurt your feelings a little bit
that it's digital
i hate digital i hate it i'm thinking
right now
like do you feel i miss film i miss film
the the the
i'm glad that i started when i did
because that was you you either
developed your own film or you
shot it and dropped it off at your
favorite lab and you just couldn't wait
for the next day i mean there was times
i'd stay up all night
until the next day when i get go pick up
my stuff and
then look at it everything else it was
that anticipation of what you're going
to get
i mean it's like late tomorrow morning
i knew it as soon as you said i was like
[Laughter]
it was too quiet for you too quiet
you'll be taking pictures in the county
jail
what you've been saying for months
there's no debt in prison now
oh this is la county jail do you accept
collect call
no i'm at the county jail pick up
ah no i don't accept the call hang up
it's done
oh i've gotten a few of those calls like
you don't know me i don't know you gene
what advice can you give a young
photographer right now that's at home
i mean right now there's nothing to take
a picture of
unless you want to take a picture
homeless people people get hit in the
head with sticks
people wiping their ass your dad went
down
remember the night i left here the other
night we were here one night
and i swear to god i was at that life by
the fire station
for some reason that light is always
green
and it was red because the fire truck
was backing up and the light was
flashing okay
and there was a dude taking a [ __ ] by
the tree i looked at the whole
i didn't see the [ __ ] coming out of his
ass nothing but what i did see was him
straighten up
take his [ __ ] and wipe it up against
the tree
with his pants down like he was packing
that man
this is a fascinating i haven't had
dinner yet
and people ask me why i'm leaving
because i saw a guy take a [ __ ] i forgot
to tell you that lee
right there right he wiped you on the
tree like a mayor
listen to me i don't mind if you take a
[ __ ] in that park a little league
i'm not gonna get mad at you i've been
there i've been there sometimes you
gotta go
yeah and you gotta [ __ ] dump but the
fact that he took the
[ __ ] onto hunger across the street from
the fire department
behind the fence and listen if the fire
truck didn't come
nobody would see him i'm not saying he
had a bad spot
but he didn't think it through i would
have gone
deeper sometimes you don't think it all
the way through
high expectations from a homeless dude
you have no idea what it is to be
sitting there
finally whoo that was tough i'm gonna
take a [ __ ] right here
and all of a sudden as you blowing that
first [ __ ] nut out
all of a sudden the fire truck decides
to come
down the block with its sirens on then
they stop the sirens
and then they beeped up and they have to
back it in
right you've seen them do it well as
they back it in the lights were flashing
his homie he straightens up he's [ __ ]
guilty right he don't even know what to
do with his hands
he's got like a t-shirt but it falls out
of his hand
so he just walks backwards and he puts
his ass against the tree
i just drove straight because i didn't
want him chasing the car
and sitting on my car and then you know
i don't play that [ __ ]
if you're gonna take a [ __ ] take a [ __ ]
in the park like a normal human being
don't think you should across the street
from the fire department
that's all i'm trying to say she wasn't
thinking it all the way through man so
let me tell you something did you even
give an answer for your your advice for
the whole
yeah give me the yeah yeah there you go
lee's on it he's lying
that's when i wish i would have had a
[ __ ] camera so that's when i make
money you have a camera if i see a guy
taking this [ __ ] i would never even know
how to [ __ ] do this
because you gotta press it and get a
like i don't do that i ain't quick like
that's a machine i see a guy taking this
[ __ ] i take that picture i will [ __ ]
send it to garcetti and then frame it
and put in the museum
like and [ __ ] with people like what do
you see in that picture
i see a poor man looking for hope i see
a [ __ ] guy
wiping his ass up against a tree all
right i'm not
there's no hope when you're wiping your
ass you can send it to our city you send
it to all your friends
at six in the morning gene i can't tell
you how many pictures of [ __ ]
i've gotten from this man he never texts
he yells at people who texts but at
seven in the morning about eight times a
year i get a picture of the biggest
nastiest [ __ ]
oh you guys see the ones lately with
blood on top of them why is there blood
on top
it's a joke jeans we're like the bloody
no i was just thinking the bloody stools
that was the name of a band once
[Laughter]
well don't try to make
your money at it because everybody's
giving stuff away
if you go on facebook you go on all
these social things
um if you're starting out you better
have a niche
or you better have a connection of some
sort
because um if i'm i'm glad i'm not
starting out because
i you know i had the drive the hunger
you got to have you got to have it in
you you got to have
you got to have some skills but right
now with the
digital stuff all you got to do is have
a credit card buy your equipment
and buy these little discs that you put
in there and
it's not like the old days where you had
to buy film i
spent thousands and thousands of dollars
on film
film you had to buy it then you had to
have it developed
and you had to make them all count or as
much as
you had to make that film count somehow
one great picture is all i needed to do
to make everything count but nowadays
people look down you see the
see them oh no i'll redo it again redo
it again and all this stuff
the advice i give it anybody is just you
know
um have a passion for it don't expect to
make
your rent money off of it don't don't
expect to pay
your car off on it just
do it because you [ __ ] love it you
love it i still
love it i take pictures of just weird
things the other day
well no not the other day it was a
couple years you don't do weddings
huh you don't do weddings i have okay
but they had to be special
one was on halloween night it was a
halloween night wedding and
everybody had to be dressed up everybody
had to be dressed up in something
so i mean it i've done one in hawaii
um it just has to be something that's
very
fun and special not your you know
traditional stuff you know i've done one
of a biker you know a biker club
you know type of wedding and uh it was
fun
so that kind of stuff yeah but uh
no i've always i've always loved music i
think i was telling you before that
in the 70s i would open up an album and
i would study the photo
who took it where did they take it who's
involved with everything
you know the uh aerosmith live bootleg
full of photos how many times did you
open your record
and just look at everything and just
study it all you know
high on balls and just gene for years i
pitched i wanted a picture show
where you grabbed an album
and broke it down but
everybody said it wouldn't work because
you got to pay for rights and [ __ ] like
that to play people's music
i wanted to show the concept of what an
album was
you know i'll never forget being in the
longest yard
and they sent me a dvd and when i opened
it up
it was just a dvd there was no
folder there was no pictures
no booklet no booklet there was no
no history i i remember opening you know
opening up albums and seeing we want to
thank the hiltons
you know they even thank the hotel chain
they say that you know
like and you know for me it was part of
you woke up on a saturday you went to
the record store
some albums you bought because of the
record the cover
just the cover didn't care what it was
what it was
if the cover was cool you know the
houses are holy
great cover the kids walking whatever
the [ __ ] they're doing you know there's
so many album covers
of us growing up that you bought the
album you know we used to have good
album covers
maybe the outlaws molly hatchet yeah
molly hatchet
always if you look at their album covers
if anybody is interested in looking at
weird album covers
they had like a viking or some [ __ ] they
had like something that was uh
but they also had kick-ass music inside
if you if you listen to it one time
after you
you know put it on and you study it
you're in they stole that from society
they stole that on
saturdays your mom used to get your hand
done
and your dad played cards
he went to his buddy's house and won and
played cards
so you knew on saturday you had the
house
from 1 15 to about 3 30
4 if mom went shopping
so you would time it just right you me
steve simone like three jerk offs would
walk from here
to i don't know
ventura and [ __ ] barham
we would walk like five miles to a
record stop to buy now
and on the way back we stopped at burger
king we knew a chick from high school
that worked at burger king
so she'd give us extra chicken
sandwiches and then on the way down the
hill you went to your drug dealer's
house and he bought a nickel bag
if he was a good drug dealer he gave you
eight joints
five dollars and you took the thing home
you you put the album on and while you
played the um
you open the album up and you clean the
pot in the middle of the almond the
seeds would fall
down to the bottom and you could skim
away the seeds
this grape in the 80s we had seeds in
our wheat
until the mexicans discovered sensamia
narcos season two mexico get your [ __ ]
together
they got the whole history lesson there
but those seeds
and then while we'd smoke we would look
at the
album cover the sleeves the band took
time they just didn't create music
while they would create music they would
hire a guy like you
to throw ideas at him and they'd put
work just as much work as they did into
the music
into the album i i took my
case of albums away but you know
this album cover simple
and to the point yeah okay
almond covers were ac dc back in black
almost didn't get released because it
was a black cover
they thought it wouldn't sell but they
had the music people had to know
what brian johnson had to bring because
that was his first
i was shocked and but what you were
talking about
going through going to the whole
procedure you know what you just did you
just
broke it down on how to buy and listen
to a record
that was it that's all i wanted
procedure you went
you knew somebody i went to a
record store called licorice pizza and i
had friends that worked there
and um you know they'd say you know
here you go you know this is check this
out this is a
you know this is this is really good
because they would play it
i got to listen to stuff like if i asked
for it it's like hey can you play me
um this record or if somebody turned me
on to something
i didn't hear it before it's like man
they'd be playing red fox
red fox's stuff to you know
um uh ted nugent to you know whatever
but you got to listen to it i hung out
more record stores than any place else
because i got to listen to it and go
okay i like this enough that i want to
buy it
and you know take it home
open it up get my right sitting
place getting my whole thing it was a
whole procedure
okay i got a cold beer uh got one ready
it was it was a whole thing but then you
had one more album to put in your rack
yeah so when people came over here a big
shot yeah you picked pick your [ __ ]
out
yep pick your album lee what are they
gonna tell you to molly what do you
think let me tell you
joey diaz is a meeting gene kirkland
thank you very much
for taking the time yeah man and coming
on for people don't know
lee got the wrong bill sent to him but
as you guys know of lee you know
he uh he got thrown out of the south
point
the nicest guy okay lee's got the kiss
of death on him for a couple years so
if anybody knows this this probably will
is gonna be a problem because
the merck park is full of lee science i
went down the last time i went to wangas
i parked by lindbergh park and the guy
asked me hey
getting loose id and i asked him what
name he had this at least i had that's
when i made him aware
so that's when he just told that when
you stole my id and why i got 15 million
dollars worth of fruit
why would i do your [ __ ] id i'm
telling you you're the head of a cartel
that 15 million sounds about right
they sent you a bill and said you made
15 16 yeah
16 million i owe 48 grand in taxes oh
yeah you're done
they got you you're done it's all over
when you go to the mall they might even
handcuff you no my mom won't let me go
she says i'll say something wrong
yeah no i know you will leave me your
watch in your wallet i'll hold it for
you
you'll see it back in about three years
oh my god
there's so listen gene the thing about
you is
we could be here till five in the
[ __ ] morning we didn't bring enough
tequila
blow so we'll have to get you the next
time jesus
anytime you want me here man i i i got
stories they just have to come out
you know once i start yakking that's it
it's a [ __ ] beautiful thing you've
had a great career from the aussie
stories to the guns and roses
to [ __ ] i can't imagine being a fan
of aerosmith's
and having to shoot him but i'd have to
do the same creepy [ __ ]
what's up with you zombo you're all
right so how many milligrams
is in that spring doesn't really matter
okay it's actually a pretty guy
not bad actually today to be very honest
with you come here take a couple more
find one
here you need a couple i'm not gonna let
you spread it's gonna go in my eye for
sure why not just shoot one in the eye
one time just see what happens
let me ask you something real quick my
friend i i hear you're doing something
uh
soon uh a pretty big project
is that something i should know about a
movie
yeah yeah yeah it's supposed to come out
next march yeah i'm doing one more day
on it
and uh hopefully that's it you want to
move it to me with anything
i [ __ ] want to go what's the problem
with you i got a [ __ ] spread again
with the hosiem
but you got me walking around like you
gave it to steve simone
steve simone says you gave it to him and
[ __ ] you gave him the clap
i don't know how true that is but it
doesn't matter anyway
yeah yeah i'm shooting the soprano movie
it's supposed to get released i think
march 12 next year
they added scenes that's all i know i'm
excited i can't wait
you're gonna be awesome i'm excited did
you watch the series
yeah you know what i didn't get into it
i've i've always caught things on the
very end of the tail end of stuff when
people have already
gotten into stuff i have uh you know
thanks to my wife she goes you got to
watch this stuff
and some of the some of the best nights
we've ever had was
watching marathon times in a row going
for it and
when um when i got rumored that uh they
were gonna do a movie
i just said i bet he's gonna be
something to do with it and then sure
enough i mean i just had that
instinct i thought oh my god you're
gonna be
because i've watched you in the longest
yard about
10 15 times oh crazy now if you
if i'm not i'll just give you a little
connection that you
now you have a little connection to gnr
right now
because were you
guys called the meme machine yes axel
rose
on the illusion tour i've got lots of
photos
he has the jersey mean machine yes
so it's like you were so it you you now
have that little you know what
here was this because this movie came
out in 2005.
yeah but the original movie was 73.
74 74 73 so the pictures i have
where he wears the black uh uh
jersey is in um
91 91 92 so he had it made up for him
and on the back it says beam machine you
know
about a month ago that movie came on the
original
about 10 o'clock how can you not watch
it my wife just went to bed
i ran in the back i did about 10 bong
hits
and when i came back he was driving to
leonard skinner
oh saturday night oh that's that's my
that's one of my favorite parts
that is just a brilliant scene then they
come into the bar and he tells them
would you bring this [ __ ] cop with you
yeah
and all cops always laugh and it's like
it's just and i it just took me back to
1974
cinema theater union city new jersey
packed house on a saturday afternoon
200 kids on seats yelling mean machine
machine meme and then you left there
going
like i just left there and i was
cheering for [ __ ] criminals what is
wrong with me
i'm a [ __ ] catholic i gotta get my
[ __ ] together
oh [ __ ] you ended up being a mean
machine
yes and lee might get you don't know
16 million on the counter wait till the
irs jumps on you tomorrow morning
if i was you i'd dump that [ __ ] mac
account when i
take all the 20s out that you can before
they [ __ ] lock your [ __ ] up
because if the county's got that the irs
has that
so they're about to file they'll close
your bank account i have to take my bank
account you'll never you'll be
i'll leave you in the office you can
sleep in here for a few months there's a
room over here
this remote there won't be a couch to
just be a nice one
i love you [ __ ] the church
what's happened now has been brought to
you by
sheath underwear now that everyone is
working in their underpants
you might as well be doing it in the
best damn
underwear around what makes sheath
underwear different
it's simple right sheet underwear has a
special
two pouch compartment that keeps your
twig
and your [ __ ] nut sack from sticking
together and by the way
the two-part compartment if you're ever
in a bang and you want to hide a couple
things in there you might as well take
your hand column
[ __ ] and it doubles as a smuggler's
underwear it's like [ __ ] goodfellas
your balls go one way and your pipes go
to the other let me tell you something
i just started wearing these again i had
they kept they were sending them to me
but i was involved with another company
and i was wearing them anyway
i love sheath
i mean perfectly and i like them
better because of the nut control i'm 57
my nuts are all over the place you're 25
if you don't want to have nuts like me
start young see i came up on [ __ ]
those
cotton underwear they didn't support
your [ __ ] nuts that's why today i
have nuts that are down to my knees
don't be stupid get these underwear
right now you don't want to have long
balls when you're 57
you can't get a date not that i'd want
to date but but
listen the balls scare me if you imagine
what they do to a human being
if i rub my nut anyway i'm turning on
a beautiful underwear commercial into a
nut commercial what my point is you
gotta take care of your nuts all right
and sheet underwear will do that for you
they're super comfortable
the fabric cradles your nut like
like a like a little [ __ ] gorilla
hand you understand it's made by an
awesome veteran named robert patton he
came up with the crazy idea
while serving this country in iraq so if
it works for a [ __ ] soldier
it's going to work for you so do me
yourself a favor
grab your nuts salute the flag and go to
sheath
underwear dot com and press code
joey j-o-e-y to get 20 off
your first order of sheets underwear 100
money-back guarantee that's sheath
underwear dot com
press joey j-o-e-y support your [ __ ]
nut sack i'm sucking
listen cock-suckers have a great weekend
don't forget i'll be on patreon all
weekend we're also on [ __ ] spotify
we're everywhere we're like dog [ __ ]
we're like dog [ __ ] we're everywhere so
just like my id yeah please he's already
you're already
now your id's on the way to [ __ ]
saudi arabia
say hello that that fight [ __ ] tent a
bunch of [ __ ] swamis from salami
using your name i'm telling you my name
is lee
whatever i can't even do the [ __ ]
accent joey
patreon.com joey diaz today i did a
video
buying weed with uncle joey you see what
i get the whole thing
i'm also gonna do a bedtime story one
night this week i just couldn't find my
daughter's book
i'm gonna read people a lullaby to sleep
[ __ ]
like count them down come to relax and
then read the book
and then i'll blow smoke in there
[ __ ] here
tell them all the worst fears are coming
true oh yeah please like if it's you i
got this
story for you tonight this one's about a
guy who they stole his identity
and you have no [ __ ] idea what
happened okay anyway
i'll see you guys monday tip top magoo i
want to thank gene kirkland
don't forget to go to genekirkland.com
the website is under construction this
guy
he's named the the photographer of the
[ __ ] rock stars
i wouldn't have him come in here if he
wasn't the [ __ ] real deal
and watch that video you're gonna love
it stay black [ __ ] have a great
weekend
kick this mule lee
[Music]
you